in Weißenfels in SachsenAnhalt versucht
die Stadt seit Jahren ihr kleines
Hallenbad zu sanieren eine lösbare
Aufgabe möchte man meinen aber wegen
Planungsfehlern und Baumängeln sind alle
Arbeiten gestoppt und 3,2 Millionen Euro
bereits versenkt und weil keiner weiß ob
das Schwimmbad überhaupt noch mal
eröffnet wird müssen alle Fördermittel
samtstrafzinsen zurückgezahlt werden
insgesamt 1,78 Millionen Euro die in
Weißenfeld sind stinksauer eine große
Schweinerei finde ich das weil hier so
viel Geld reingeflossen ist dass sie das
gemacht haben die haben gebaut die haben
gemert und dann auf immer Schluss Kner
will daav verantwortlich sein ich find
es eine bodenlose Frechheit ich find es
traurig dass ich nicht mehr mit meinen
Kumpels und Freunden hier schwimmen kann
und Trieren kann das weisenfelser
Hallenbad DDR Modelltyp anklamm wird
1969 gebaut und erfüllt jahrzehntelang
seinen Zweck im Herbst 2020 beginnt die
Stadt mit der Sanierung der Plan das
Gebäude soll erhalten und die
Energieeffizienz verbessert werden doch
schon kurz nach Baubeginn gibt's erste
Probleme im Oktober 2022 stellt dann ein
Gutachter gravierende Mängel bei der
neuen Heizung und Lüftung und bei den
neuen Sanitäranlagen fest die Arbeiten
werden gestoppt seitdem ist hier nichts
mehr passiert für den weißen felsers
Schwimmverein geht's mittlerweile um die
Existenz
wir haben ungefähr 40% unserer
Mitglieder verloren ganz klar wir haben
in weißenfall zum mal keinen Domizil
mehr zum Trainieren zum wettkämpf
Ausrichten und ja jetzt müssen wir eben
lange Wege auf uns nehmen um überhaupt
dem schimmsport noch nachzugehen wer ist
schuld am millionendisaster im
Weißenfelser Rathaus lässt das der neue
Bürgermeister prüfen und weiter heißt es
schriftlich die Kommunalaufsichtsbehörde
des Landes SachsenAnhalt für derzeit
eine verwaltungsinterne Prüfung durch
untersucht werden mögliche Versäumnisse
im
Verwaltungshandeln vielen Bürgern reicht
das nicht sie haben Angst dass ihr
Schwimmbad eine Bauruine bleibt ich
finde das einfach nur schlimm dass
bestimmte Leute das in Sand gesetzt
haben vielleicht nicht mehr haftbar
gemacht werden können das ist ja nun
keine Raketentechnik ne in schwimpad zu
sieren und dass dass da so eine Panne
passiert ist und das so dermaßen schief
geht das kann glaube ich kaum jemand
hier verstehen laut einer neuen
machbarkeitsstud hier soll es sage und
schreibe noch mal 7 Millionen Euro
kosten um das Hallenbad fertig zu bauen
und zu retten ob und wie es hier
weitergeht muss der Stadtrat nächstes
Jahr
entscheiden